une de ces étoiles et mon étoile et je
sais que mon étoile sera toujours là
pour moi comme une voix rassurante qui
dirait ne renonce pas à petit ya un
nouveau qui emménage ici j'espère que
celui là n'aura jamais entendu parler de
moi ce n'est pas si souvent dans la vie
on a la chance de pouvoir redémarrer à
zéro
cette fois les choses seront noires
jerry brown avait besoin d'un miracle
j'ai besoin de connaître le secret pour
arriver à faire quelque chose de grand
tout ce qu'il aura ses snoopy cette
année bien le monde car si tu veux
vraiment impressionner les gens qui doit
leur montrer que tu as un galion
ouah
century fox présente aux caisses nous
pille on met le paquet
sa ligne a permis une patty mélodies
charlie brown c'est la nouvelle qui
arrive
elle est passible tout ça né de
l'imagination de charles hours et des
créateurs de l'âge de glace et bio voici
l'incroyable histoire
voilà qui va aller où c'est un garçon à
la pipe de chiens n'arrive pas à croire
que je vais parler à la nouvelle et de
son chien
bonjour elle a dit bonjour nous piller
les pilotes
le film
mais rêver en grand